and now on book tv nomi prinz discusses
our current economic situation in the
u.s and her book black tuesday a
historical novel about the 1929 economic
crash this is about an hour 20 minutes
good evening
i want to welcome everybody to the
strand i hope you enjoy our new event
space which is located in our rare book
floor as a way of introduction i'm nancy
white and i'm the owner of the strand
the strand was founded by my grandfather
in 1927 it's been
around for three generations
of my family
so
a contrary to the so-called experts who
say the kindles and the ipads and the
next cool devices are going to wipe out
bookstores we believe that people do not
want to just be sitting home at home
tethered to their gadgets even though i
see matt brought his device to the
bookstore
but we're just planning to serve the
book community for a long long time
tonight i am thrilled to welcome back
naomi prims
for the launch of her first historical
novel black tuesday this is the second
time that she's been at the strand and
she says that she only signs at
independent bookstores love her for that
[Applause]
so with the mounting frustration with
wall street and the recession this novel
and topic is extremely timely timely so
this um and thank you special thank you
to demos the nonpartisan multi-issue
think tank for co-sponsoring this event
and they're located here in new york
city
so we have we have a lively group of
panelists here tonight um none of which
are afraid of controversy
including matt to be to be leave
taiwan
rich benjamin that's a lot easier who'll
talk about the current financial climate
back tuesday is a
black tuesday is a character-driven book
that vividly portrays new york on the
cusp of the great stock market crash of
1929.
it captures the romance and desperation
of one of the most fascinating
historical times
nomi prims left a lucrative career at
goldman sachs and bear stearns after a
decade to pen three non-fiction
whistleblower books it takes a pillage
other people's money
and jacked
exposing fraud and deception from
wall street to
washington her first novel the trail is
a thriller set in the corrupt banking
world and it was written under pseudomen
you'll have to tell us why and but she's
a senior fellow at demos and a frequent
commentator for all kinds of media pbs
fox by fox msnbc
cnbc
cnn bbc and other global media outlets
matt is a contributing editor for
rolling stone he writes about
politics and finance
in one article he famously described
goldman sachs as a great vampire squid
wrapped about the face of humanity
relentlessly jamming its blood funnel
into anything that smells like money
he's authored five books many of which
we have here
including the new york times bestseller
great derangement and grif topia
and he's recently became a contributor
for current tv's countdown with keith
oberman
rich benjamin down at the end is the
author yay
searching for witopia an improbable
journey to the heart of white america
which was the winner of 2009 editors
choice award from book list and the
american library association rich
regularly appears all over the media
including on npr msnbc c-span new york
times
usa today and cnn.com he's a
contributing producer of short short
documentaries
documentariesfortime.com
in partnership with cnn and he's a
senior fellow at demos
um so for a little bit of tonight's
format we're going to have a
conversation then we want to open up the
mic to your questions it's a really big
crowd here so if you don't mind just
standing um standing up and i'll hand
you them and just wait a second for me
to hand you the mic so everybody
can hear you and then the authors are
going to stick around and sign copies of
their books also a special thanks to
c-span for filming tonight
and for the work they do to inspire and
educate us
so please join me in welcoming some of
america's great contemporary
whistleblowers and advocates of
financial reform naomi prims and her
panelists to the strand thank you all
hi my name is rich benjamin i'm a senior
fellow at demos and first of all i'd
like to welcome you guys who make this
event possible
and i want to thank stran such a beloved
beloved institution for we book lovers
here in new york and i want to thank
demos which as nancy mentioned is a
multi-issue think tank which works for
three overarching goals the first of
which is a more equitable prosperous
economy
the second of which is the democracy
where more of us can participate and the
third of which is a public sector that
works for the common good
now i want to
offer a different angle in introducing
our other panelists uh
i got this email in july from nomi and
it said hey rich i've written a novel
called black tuesday
right here
and i'm thinking word
nummy wrote a book about
african-american tuesday
she had to clarify black tuesday of
course referring to dark tuesday in the
stock market crash of 1929 and
immediately i could see the timeliness
of this topic
although naomi could write a book called
african-american tuesday
now for those of you who don't know nomi
is such a dogged incisive
elegant voice
for progressive values and i'm so
honored to introduce her
what you may not know in which was
alluded to before is
nomi was part of the one percent before
she joined the 99
uh nomi was a wall streeter and not only
was she a wall streeter she was a
managing director at goldman sachs which
is such an achievement in itself in
terms of her brilliance
but
now she's based in la and she's writing
full time and i want to briefly
show you her novels because that really
gives a wonderful trajectory of her
thinking and her career
the first
other people's money the corporate
mugging of america
secondly jacked how conservatives are
picking your pocket
whether you voted for them or not
third whistleblowing book it takes a
pillage
behind the bailouts bonuses and backroom
deals from wall street to washington
by the way nomi is also the queen of
titles in case you hadn't noticed
so you can learn more about know me at
www.com
and i just introduce her with a great
deal of pride and a great deal of
affection and we miss her here on
the right coast
so know me prince
now matt taivi you might figure you know
matt's a bit of an underachiever and a
boring writer
seriously matt is a regular contributor
for rolling stone and he has made such a
name
to really exposing the underbelly
in the dark side of our financial
institutions in this country
you read the beautiful
quote
that matt had to say about nomi's former
employer goldman sachs
and i'll briefly
read from uh mass blog today you can
find matt
at his rolling stone blog
when he's not on countdown
matt wrote today quote
what nobody is comfortable with is a
movement in which virtually the entire
spectrum of middle class and poor
americans is on the same page
railing against incestuous political and
financial corruption on wall street and
in washington
the reality is that occupy wall street
and the millions of middle americans who
make up the tea party are natural allies
and should be on the same page about
most of the key issues
and that's a story our media won't want
you to know for you to handle
i have a gripe to pick with matt
as
nancy mentioned i published a book
called searching for wytopia in 2009 an
improbable journey to the heart of white
america
in 2010 matt released griftopia
bubble machines vampire squids and the
long con that is breathtaking that is
breaking america
so please visit matt and welcome matt
and matt we're delighted to have you
thank you
sorry to steal the title
so
let's just begin let's just jump right
in what we'll do is we'll have a
conversation and then we'll open it up
to questions and no me let's hear about
black tuesday
um well thank you for the introduction
thank you nancy for that lovely
introduction thank you strand thank
demos um thank the lower east side
tenement museum where i spent a lot of
time and took a lot of tours doing uh
some of the research for this book thank
you grandfather for two years before the
time that this book took place
starting this bookstore
because a lot has happened and it's
wonderful to gather here tonight for
that
um
obviously a lot going on in the world
with respect to and particularly in new
york on wall street and so forth that
we're just talking about that matt talks
about with respect to what
is an uprising
amongst people who are just sick of the
way things are economically and want it
to actually be different not to have
talk about how it might be different but
to actually live differently and i we
are i'm sure going to talk about that a
lot tonight but what i want to do first
is take you back 82 years
to a period in time that was
both very different and very
similar to today
and that was part of my inspiration for
coming up with the story for this book
is that a lot of what what i do what
rich does what math does you know we
talk about numbers we do talk about
people who talk about stats but it's
really in a novel that you can
also look at the emotions behind that
the sort of the sheer humanity um of
struggling and what you bear and what
you think you don't want to deal with
and what you ultimately
come to achieve and there's a lot of
that in this book too no one's a natural
hero
least of all the main character lyla
khan she comes to what she ultimately
does in this book through
a lot of internal struggle and a lot of
difference different situations um i'm
gonna read three brief passages from the
book to give you a sense of um you know
what she went through what things were
like on both sides of the divide um the
one percent the 99 percent but back then
and it wasn't too different and um
go from there so the first passage
lila lives in this fifth floor walk up
on orchard street in an apartment that
she shares with
four other people um her old aunt rosa
her little sister rachel and her two
peasants and um it's tiny and cramped as
as you can imagine back in the 20s back
in that day back at that time
and she's having a conversation with her
aunt about this
idealism that she's seeing sort of
activism that's kind of happening
amongst the workers and the people she
knows on that side and how she really
feels about it which is which is not
sure
lila eyed her aunts hollow cheekbones
and defiant limbs the silver streaks and
the wiry raven hair that she wore
braided down her back she felt her
throat constrict listen to me go on said
rosa with a labored flick of her wrists
of course things will be fine enough
with thesaurus how are things with you
and nelson fine answer lyla that's all
just fine
i don't know i wish he could be happier
he's always going on about how miserable
things are fighting about something ever
since his brother was shot i'm afraid he
may join the gangs again i guess i guess
i'm tired of it i'm tired of not being
the fighter he thinks i should be
rosa nodded and swayed her body back and
forth her eyes closed as i transported
her to the internal movie of her past
he's a good man with a loyal heart you
should try to see where he's coming from
should should should
rosa's words made lila feel inadequate
she could not help but think of the
stranger at the morning spot
the morning spot's a diner down on wall
street
did he have any warmth any goodness she
knew nothing about him and yet he had
somehow burrowed into her heart
i now replied lyla but that won't make
him easier to deal with you remember
what i told you when you first came here
a young girl of 14 not knowing a word of
english she asked i do tanta
lila braced herself for a speech she'd
heard many times before it was her duty
to listen diligently but her heart
impelled her to flee she loved her aunt
with all her being but that love imposed
a burden that she wished she could shake
i told you that in order to succeed in
america you must find your purpose and
always help those less fortunate than
you
i know which is exactly what nelson
strives to do every day i know it's just
that you and me have such courage as
patience i wish i did instead i just
want to get out of here
lila stopped herself but rosa seemed to
understand exactly what she meant
sometimes you don't find your cause lyla
said her aunt with a little smile your
cause finds you there is a little fight
buried in all of us
um and that's kind of one of the
messages in the book is that you know
not all of us start out knowing anything
about the direction of our life or or
fights we might have or how we might
react in those particular situations i
mean certainly when i started on wall
street i was lyla's age i was 19. and um
i had no idea
what it was about and it took me working
there many many years to finally finally
figure it out and ultimately to get out
and share it
but but you don't know you don't know
the answers and and you don't always do
the right thing and i think that's
that's a part of all of us and
sometimes you come upon
the right thing
in a really difficult way
um one other scene
i'm going to read this one and one more
um this is a scene where now she's
lyla is working on on this in this diner
on wall street and she goes home every
night to this dingy little apartment on
the lower east side not not very far
away at all but but millions of miles
away in terms of the conversations that
happen in the money divide and
everything else
but she's just discovered a secret about
this wall street banker who comes to
frequent her diner
lila arrived home to a glorious may
evening
vibrant swaths of magenta tangerine and
rose stripe the blue dust sky like the
swirls around the candy canes at cohen's
sweet shop on rivington street
the air carried a gentle breeze
throughout the lower east side
lila was so gleefully distracted with
thoughts of roderick and the morgans
that she circled her neighborhood
several times before reaching her
building
rachel was playing stoop bowl with a few
of her friends the brow under her raven
ringlets was damp with the sweat of
competition their building had the
tallest stoop in the neighborhood seven
steps in all so it was a magnet for kids
children were laughing and scampering
after every stray ball that bounced down
the sidewalk the twins were unofficial
neighborhood champs jonathan would wind
his arm like a yankee pitcher on opening
night he could go 20 points without
missing a catch and finish a game with
100 points joshua had stopped playing a
few years ago hey cuz jonathan called to
lila mid-pitch his hair tousled messed
the sleeves of his work shirt rolled up
to his elbows your sister's gaining on
me she's out to take my title it's war
i bet on rachel by the left is that all
my talent means to you ask jonathan
grinning sorry jonathan rage is no
slouch we all better watch out for her
and would you mind making room for me to
pass through the big game do we have to
stop now moaned rachel i'm having my
best run
of course you don't reefka answered
arriving breathless at their stoop she
hung onto the iron railing her ample
breasts breathing heathing
i haven't seen your sister in weeks
we're going to do a little ketchup so
keep beating jonathan okay okay agreed
rachel grabbing the ball not needing the
extra encouragement reefka lila hugged
her friend so good to see you but i'm
late for dinner rosa will be waiting for
me to help with the finishing touches
rosa definitely does not need your help
in the cooking department reefka
chuckled now tell me what's new please
my life is one big bore right now i need
to come up with better fish stories for
joshua or move on it's tragic how's your
crush
lilac couldn't suppress a wide grin that
unleashed her dimples see there's news
exclaimed reefka tell me okay but let's
go over to feinberg's hardware away from
miss big ears over there she gestured to
rachel the two walked a few buildings
down the block they strode past marcus's
shoe store and harold cigar shop
sniffing wafts of sweet tobacco they
passed another set of kids playing
hopscotch and a third playing stickball
everyone was out tonight after they sat
down on feinberg's steps lila blurted
out the latest development are you
kidding me
rifka's emerald eyes nearly bulged out
of their sockets he's a morgan flesh and
blood of the richest man in the world
and he talks to you
um
and that was part of what was going on
at the time there was there was a
a cynicism amongst a very small group of
people about what went down on wall
street because it was it was very
secretive there were bankers down there
there was money made down there there
was a stock market everybody was talking
about but but it was still pretty
secretive and it still is today but but
it was even more so then
and um
yet there was this adoration of it like
it must be so amazing you know this
guy's making this money what are they
doing what what what crazy things are
going on down there and until the market
really crashed
and things got really bad there wasn't
this notion of a connection between
those things that went down there and
how it was impacting a stupal game on
the steps on orchard straight
and just as a background to that one of
the women that i had interviewed and i
talked to a lot of people about their um
experiences during the great depression
um was kind of a little bit rachel who
is the little sister of lila the main
character and she used to tell me that
you know they didn't have a lot of money
so they would they would have a ball and
this ball would be basically everybody's
game and it was stoop ball and you'd
find the stairs and you'd basically
throw the ball catch it and there'd be
like these tournaments going on on the
streets you know you'd find a stick
you'd play stickball
whereas uptown on park avenue and so
forth you had all of the the latest toys
the latest fashions the latest
everything and it was a tremendous
tremendous difference um as again it is
today even even more pronounced
back then
but
obviously there's there's a cost that
comes with that difference on our
economy on people and people back then
and the bankers that ultimately
perpetuate some of what happens don't
always know what they're doing and some
do and herein lies the problem her crush
is
a morgan partner
in real life there are 40 partners at
morgan bank he was the 41st in my book
but
has a lot of the elements of the others
so this last scene i'm going to read
will probably
take you into today a little bit but um
it was the afternoon for real of 1929
october uh tuesday 1929 the 29th
and um roderick the morgan partner had
to go into the secret meeting at the new
york
stock exchange
right now if you imagine the triangle
down on wall street there's a stock
exchange there's the old morgan bank
which was the the first big morgan bank
and then there's federal hall it's kind
of a triangle
obviously it was the same then and
for real they
in the middle of this day when the
market was going crazy and crashing
there was a notice given to the morgan
bank that there was going to be a secret
meeting held at the new york stock
exchange to talk about what to do
bankers had several days before that on
black thursday pooled lots of their
money together and thought they could
save the markets and they did for a
little bit the media said that was all
great and then they all plummeted again
and so now there are several days later
and they know they know that everything
they've basically created and lied about
is going to come crumbling down so
there's a secret of the new york stock
exchange to decide what to do and it was
told to people that were coming over
from from morgan um not to let anybody
basically see them come over because
that would incite a riot you know
imagine there's all these people down in
the exchange everybody's angry and and
the actual um
this was only reported much later it
wasn't reported at the time the meeting
that was held was actually held in
secret they went up the back stairs of
the exchange
to avoid being caught
the exchange was the last place roderick
wanted to be it was just like his uncle
to stay away from the fray always in the
shadows he grabbed his overcoat and hat
and followed lamont from across the
lower lobby of morgan roderick saw a
cluster of men before the bank's doors
yelling at the morgan guards with fist
clenching stock certificates lamont said
not that way out the back
the two men exited the bank through the
same steel doors that normally opened
for truckloads of gold bars once outside
they had no choice but to barge through
the crowds to reach the back door of the
exchange across the narrow street
fortunately there were less people on
this side of the exchange than raging
directly in front of it but the task was
still far from simple just when they
reached the back of the exchange two
guards told them to wait outside so that
people wouldn't spot two morgan partners
entering they might just kill you
said an exchange guard
ryder adjusted his hat to cover his eyes
and waited by lamont he was looking down
at his shoes when a man wearing a gray
overcoat and matching bowler hat marched
up to him and punched him in the stomach
roderick doubled over may rot in hell
said the man before he spit in
roderick's face and ran off
on that happy note
um
there there was obviously a lot a lot of
visceral anger back then we we see
that anger today
but when i started
writing this book
it was the story the notion of this
young girl who
really didn't know anything about any of
this
not about bankers not about wall street
not about fighting not about labor
activists you know she just wanted to
grow up in this america have the dream
that everyone talked about
when they immigrated here and and that
was all
and she comes upon what some discoveries
that she can't ignore even though she
she tries really hard to and that's a
lot of the conflict in the book is that
you know sometimes you ignore ignore
ignore until until you can't and and
what do we do at that moment of our
humanity or our situation our personal
lives in an aggregate situation for the
country or whatever to stand up um and
what's our internal struggle in doing
that so she does go through a lot of
that and i think today um there's
there's a lot of that allowed now i mean
there's a lot of anger there's there's
matt's quote
there's all of the stuff that we know
has been imposed upon
the economy on the conditions of this
country by virtue of criminal activity
by virtue of fraud by virtue of
inflating the value of things that
shouldn't be inflated um and and what
we're seeing now is really no different
the details might be different but but
the mechanisms the people are all the
same really they're just
you know like like nancy's here instead
of her grandfather you know it's like
jamie dimon is here instead of jack
morgan
um but in a in a worse way
um and and i think that's also the
impetus for um
learning from our past and hoping that
you know maybe we can bring the good
parts of what happened in that pass
forward um because not all of the
bankers at this time got what they
should have gotten on that none of them
uh were actually arrested none of them
were actually tried for
securities fraud or anything like that
at the time but sounds familiar and
which is very familiar which i know matt
will talk about but we did we did have a
situation where there was an
understanding that the country had to be
protected um and that in the midst of
the great depression that follow the
stock market crash in 1929 the the
foundation of the country that the core
of of uh
the financial system had to be protected
vis-a-vis the population um and that was
part of the reason why they split up the
banks ultimately in 1933 it was the idea
that you can't be doing fraudulent
things and then crash the whole economy
however it is that happens and either a
get away with it or b get to continue
doing it with our help i.e the
government's help
and so back then they had that
distinction they had the glass-steagall
act passed which divided banks and
basically slapped back uh
not their all the speculative activities
but at least gave the population
protections um that we don't have now
um which is a sad lack of historical
understanding um in today's world
but all of that aside
going through it at the time and if you
can imagine going back and seeing kind
of simpler world
as a person just coming here and and
figuring it out
with their heart with their head
struggling between family struggling
between the wealthy and the the poor and
everything else you know you get a sense
for
how we are really not that different
from from how we were 82 years ago
so
that
i just want to say one thing about about
matt in addition before he starts um
responding no no
when he wrote the um the piece about the
vampire squid um
which was my old old firm i had so many
calls
um
about him
and um we didn't we didn't actually know
each other at the time um it was it was
sort of like who is this you know i mean
i i knew his work i didn't know him we
hadn't had a personal conversation i
think i had so many uh calls about that
piece and about this guy
um that i reached out and i'm just glad
to say we we you know have become
friends and um i i deeply admire this
man's work and um i'm sure you guys all
do too so excellent
well that was it was great um i have a
lot to say about nomi uh but just a
couple of really quick things before i
start first of all rich i'm really sorry
for stealing your title
uh
yeah i didn't you know i saw it i
thought that sounds catchy i'll take
that
second thing
before we go on i just want to say how
cool it is
for me personally to be able to appear
at the strand i've been buying books
from those bins outside since i was like
this tall and like literally half the
books of my bookshelves come from the
store and one for marina either this one
or the one that used to be downtown so
my wife and i used to go there every
weekend and come out with you know
stacks this big so this is a big honor
for me and
i'm very happy to be here i'm glad you
all came out tonight um
oh this is this is a great for me to be
able to come out and and talk about uh
nomi and nomi's book uh just to
explain a little bit about where where
i'm coming from with regard to to know
me and what i think she meant to
um
this period to a lot of journalists like
me i just want to tell my story about
how i came to to know her
i think my my story was kind of typical
for a lot of political journalists uh up
until 2008
most people who cover politics in you
know
national american politics really didn't
know anything about economics at all
our whole
modus operandi for covering politics was
covering the economy excuse me was to
look at
the stock market and inflation and maybe
unemployment figures
and and that was it if the stock market
was up we would say the economy was good
and if inflation was low the economy was
good and that was really about it most
people didn't understand anything else i
can tell you that with 100 certainty
that the people on the campaign trail
who cover politics for a living know
absolutely nothing about economics and
we have one of the the sort of
precipitating incidents for me
is there something we can do about that
uh
feedback no
okay
um
does everyone remember the whole drill
baby drill speech that mccain
uh did in the summer of 2008 while i was
on i was covering mccain i was on the
mccain campaign plane
and i remember we were in kenner
louisiana
and he was sort of unveiling a new
version of that speech and um
you know after
and of course mccain was talking about
was this the surge in gas prices uh that
summer everyone remember gas prices went
through the roof and and he was
basically saying oh if we just drilled
in the gulf of mexico then those you
know somehow that would magically make
gas prices go down um so he gives this
speech and and all the reporters are
filing back into our little you know
private prison which is the campaign
plane and um
and uh one of the tv reporters is like a
mccain what a jerk you know as if as if
uh drilling in the gulf of mexico has
anything to do with why gas prices are
going up and i kind of turned to him and
i'm kind of raising my hand and i said
does anybody here actually know why gas
prices are going up and it was like
the cartoons you know where the crickets
come in you know like
literally nobody knew and i and i uh i
kind of turned to one of these uh
another reporter who was sitting next to
me and i'm like
doesn't that make us all frauds and he's
like dude you're just figuring that out
now you know
so
so there was that you know so so then
the crash happens like you know a couple
of months later and suddenly this whole
army of ignoramuses
who don't know anything about the
economy are suddenly given these
assignments like go figure out what just
happened
uh and then tell everybody else about it
like you're an expert and uh so i was
one of those people who was like given
this daunting assignment of explaining
all of these labyrinthine you know
machinations that led to the financial
crisis of 2008 and i was one of these
people who didn't even know how to
balance a checkbook so
i'm starting from square one and i
remember i started making a whole bunch
of calls to people in the industry
and i remember like the first time
somebody explained
credit default swaps to me
and they were saying oh you know two
financial institutions are basically
making they sign a contract with each
other and if you know x person defaults
on his loan then this bank gets the full
value of the the loan but if he doesn't
default on it then this person continues
paying uh that that party you know a
regular payment every month and i'm
sitting here listening to this and like
that sounds just like gambling you know
that is that economics and you know
these guys on wall street who are
calling they were saying no no you don't
understand it's it's very sophisticated
it's it's not it's not just gambling
it's really it's it's a mechanism for
lessening risk and you know they had all
this verbiage that they were cloaking
all this in but it sounded really fishy
to me and then you know then it got into
collateralized debt obligations and you
know the more people explained this to
me you know i was i was
talking to them and i was saying so let
me get this straight so you take a whole
bunch of subprime loans that are
basically
worthless or junk rated they're
extremely risky and then you somehow
sprinkle a bunch of magic dust on them
and they turn into a rated loans that
you can sell to pension funds and you
know dutch trade unions and other
victims all around the globe and and
they're like yeah i know and then i'm
like well that
that sounds just like the guys on the
street who sell prada bags and you know
gucci watches they're not real you know
how is that any different from just
crime and and they're like no you don't
understand it's it's you know it's
economics it's it's a risk management
tool it's you know it's it's creates
liquidity that's the phrase they always
it creates liquidity
uh so you know your instinct is to say
is to like run with a headline that just
says crazy as [ __ ] imaginable you know
like
like this can't possibly be happening
and
but i think like a lot of reporters you
know i i was hesitant because
most of us had never met
any people from that world you know none
of us had any actual access to people
like
lloyd blankfein or jamie dimon we didn't
get to talk to them i mean even
even presidential candidates most of us
have gotten to sit down and talk to
these people
but we don't have access to the captains
of uh finance and at least political
reporters don't
and uh and so we didn't really know how
it worked and and so a lot of us were
really hesitant to make judgments about
it then you and add to the fact that the
entire financial press was treating what
happened as just sort of a grotesque
accident and you know a thousand-year
flood this this is just you know
economics these things happen it wasn't
crime it wasn't fraud you know it's just
a whole bunch of people who made some
bad judgments about the market and these
are seemingly smart people on television
and there's a whole army of people on
cnbc who are acting like this isn't
crazy and that it isn't crime and so you
you hesitate uh because you don't have
that personal experience and
uh and so what was really needed was for
somebody from that world
to come forward and explain to us yes
this is this was nuts it's exactly as
crazy as crazy as it seems like and
moreover let me tell you a little bit
about what these people are like so you
can understand the motivations in the
background and that's really what nomi i
think nomi's role has been in this
entire fiasco uh she's she was one of
the first sort of wit first person
witnesses to history to come forward and
to confirm
the superficial conclusions that all
these outsiders were were drawing but we
just didn't we couldn't know for sure
unless we had somebody who was actually
on the inside explaining a lot of this
to us and you know i i had the uh it was
shortly after i think my goldman piece
came out i i
i forget who called who first but um but
we ended up meeting in new york in a
jewish deli
in uh in the diamond district
uh
yeah they closed at the dairy luncheon
did anyone know that place um
uh and we sat and nomi basically you
know she ran through her the history of
her experiences at you know particularly
bear stearns and goldman and she told me
a lot about what
you know her career had been like and
what her apprehensions were and why she
ended up leaving and
and you know for me it was uh as a
reporter was it was invaluable because
you know not just confirming
intellectually
what all these instruments were and how
they worked and and why why why they
blew up but it was also you know what
how these what the rooms look like where
the where these deals went down what the
attitude was of the people who were who
were doing these deals you know from
from on the outside one has to one comes
to the conclusion that these people must
have been looking at you know
numbers there must have been internal
objections people in the risk management
departments coming forward saying dude
don't we can't do this it's gonna blow
up the company and there must have been
people who said now forget about that
we'll worry about that later and and it
wasn't until i met nomie that i that i
realized that
you know i had somebody to tell me yes
firsthand yes this did happen yes these
people were routinely ignored and that's
why a lot of these disasters happened so
um
all of this you know there weren't a
whole lot of people from this world who
came who came forward to tell us what it
was like on the inside and so she's
really an invaluable resource in that
regard and i think you know what what
she's able to do with black tuesday
there are a lot of things that we can't
imagine
except in the realm of fiction because
they couldn't possibly happen in reality
like for instance we're never going to
have a trial a fraud trial of a jamie
diamond or a lloyd blankfein in this
country it's just we're these people are
not going to be dragged into court and
forced to answer uh for their crimes uh
and make no mistake about it this is
another key point that nomi
her experience brings out and she bears
out in the book you know there were a
lot of people who were trying to say
that what happened in the crash was the
work of a few bad apples here on the
side and underlings that the guys up at
the top couldn't possibly have been
aware that they were selling you know
mismarked instruments unknowingly and
unloading them on customers that's
complete crap
none of this could have happened without
the full
and total participation of the got at
the very guys at the very top of these
companies and she makes that plane but
you know her her novel comes to a
crescendo at the end and there's a
there's a trial scene where a character
you know the jack morgan character who's
you know sort of like titan of industry
is actually dragged into court for fraud
and forced to you know come face to face
with the people who bought
these uh you know these
dicey investment trusts which are very
similar to the to the cdos of our modern
time although they're a little bit more
primitive and
that's exactly what we're not going to
see now is everyone heard about this
foreclosure deal that the ag's are
cooking up now the state attorneys
general uh that's going to be sort of a
unified settlement that's going to give
the banks immunity from
all kinds of
legal liability well it's precisely
because of that deal that we're not
going to have
gigantic class action lawsuits of of
defrauded investors who are going to
drag these guys in the court and prove
uh that they all committed fraud that
they knowingly disguised the crappiness
of these loans as they were selling them
as triple a rated securities around the
world
we're never going to get that seen
inside a courtroom we're never going to
see that evidence dragged out it's been
years now nobody has gone to jail for
any of this stuff and it's it's just not
going to happen unless unless more
pressure is brought to bear from you
know these people downtown
we're just never going to see that scene
except you know in in nomi's book and
it's a it's a great place to come
you know face to face with what the
evidence would be uh if we were actually
able to see it and so i think it's an
invaluable opportunity for all of us and
and the novel was a really cool thing
and i think everybody should read it so
uh
[Applause]
let me ask you both a question sure um
[Music]
let's say
after freud novels have become about
psychology so i want to ask you guys
about the psychology of wall street
because when you go to occupy wall
street a lot of people are frustrated
and pissed off at what has went down in
you know the last uh seven to eight
years so the question is tell us know me
about the villain in your character
in mad tibi
someone has said in order to work at the
highest levels of wall street you have
to be a sociopath i mean that's a direct
quote
what is your
understanding of people's motives and
people's psychology
over the last five years and what's gone
on so in the novelistic sense and in the
real life sense
um yeah i mean basically i i think i
said they're sociopaths
but i because there has to be a
clear
separation of how you act and who you
think you are
at those top levels and not because
they're ceos not because you're running
the morgan bank but because of
everything that made you able to take
that position
and and i i continue we could talk i
continue to to think about this just in
a more psychological emotional sense you
know are you a sociopath first and
that's how you get to that position like
is it a latent quality
um no i mean it is it and and when you
get there it sort of it sort of flushes
out
um or you know when you get the power is
that sort of like you know water on a
plant and it i i don't know or is it
something that that uh you know it's
it's a late human thing um or inhuman
thing but um
one of the things that struck me in in
looking at the history of of the morgan
bank and jack morgan who's you know jp
morgan's um
son
is that uh when he was actually called
to trial in 1933 and this is for real in
in washington at the pecora commission
trials that looked into all of what wall
street had done up until the 29 crash um
he was like really steely and really
calm and and the way the media portrayed
it at the time you know he's he's he's
so cool and he's so calm and he's so you
know there was a little circus
a mini girl or something that stepped on
and on his lap and and he was so nice to
her and and the way like after all of
what happened there was this turning
around of of of the media
almost embracing the same people they're
also running headlines about
sensationally uh the pakora trials so it
was it was just always this weird sort
of dichotomy of you know they're up
there and and and so forth and what i
did in the novel and i don't want to
give away the scene because it's it's
not
things happen there are twists and stuff
but but but the the jack morgan
character really um is based on jack
morgan uh the morgan bank really is is
is morgan bank and and there's a lot of
elements i think of of crime and forget
calling it securities forget labeling it
as anything complicated lying about
something for profit
you know that that that is very simple
to achieve
you know it's it's as simple as a
signature on
a document it's as simple as two
separate documents that say different
things
you know it doesn't have to be a
complicated cdo credit link derivative
times a million like it doesn't need to
be that the mechanism for
pulling one over on anyone who buys this
stuff
requires that same sense of separatism
from the people that are buying it
and to me that's a sociopathic quality
now now in here and again not giving
away the plot but there are other
elements that that flesh out the
sociopathic quality of the villain um
which you can read but but i think that
the elements of one kind of crime versus
another kind of crime
are pretty much the same
yeah i
i totally agree i mean first
i think the the one of the first ways
you have to answer that question is is
to identify what happened like what's a
typical
crime that went on during this period
this this recent period is take a um you
know a banker is going to sell
uh you know 250 million dollars of
mortgage-backed securities to
let's say the state pension fund of
minnesota so let's all be clear about
what this is some guy who knows he's
selling
a gigantic load of extremely risky
subprime mortgages that are likely to
blow up he's selling a whole bunch of
crap to a state punch pension fund so
that's the
retirement savings of
working class people janitors teachers
policemen firemen this guy is going to
basically steal from old ladies and and
old people that's that's what he's doing
when he's when he's selling this big
block of mortgage-backed securities to a
state pension fund or to calpers or
where whatever
and in order to do that i mean you're
going to make an enormous amount of
money and you're never going to see
those people and all you got to do is
sign a few documents and hit a few
strokes in your
on your computer and you're emotionally
i think right i mean these guys are
completely dissociated from from the
results of of their activities and i
think a lot of them
uh they they came to genuinely believe
in
the righteousness of what they were
doing they they they believed that
somehow uh this was uh you know the
survival of the fittest that somehow all
this this trading this capital
capitalist activity was weeding out the
week and and it was going to create
liquidity and somehow ultimately help
the economy in the end
but the reality is what they were doing
is just stealing from old people and and
and the weak and there's no way to do
that unless unless you completely cut
off
your conscience and
morality i mean i think it gets back to
that in that famous experiment where
people are told to turn the dial if and
that they're going to hear the screams
in the other room and and they they what
the results show is that people tend to
do that as long as an authority figure
tells them that it's okay
uh and i think that's what went on in
this in this community there was a
mantra that kind of existed generally
that this stuff was all right right and
and
this is the way you made money right it
wasn't just all right it was your job
right right you had to right so
we'd love to hear from you guys so we're
going to circulate a mic and if you
could just ask a concise question
and please speak into the mic because
you're being recorded thank you
hi well um this is a really awesome
honor um so thank you for doing this
my question is uh speaking about
training for which you get into these
jobs what part of the problem is you
know rooted in the fact that academic uh
economics is sort of
uh has this inherent problem in which
professors or people write papers but
they don't have to disclose who funded
the papers so they could write like uh
documents about oh you know
currency exchanging is so much you know
this is great invention but they don't
have to actually disclose at 4x the you
know currency trader is the one that
sponsored the paper and how if that's
the case do we like turn that back how
can we force
academia to like disclose information if
they're getting funded by certain
financial institutions when they write
papers
um i mean i think your question is part
of part of the bigger issue of um
the transparency notion of what happens
on on wall street and whether it's the
papers that people write about or the
articles or whatever and what actually
goes on and there's there's still a lot
of of sort of cloak and dagger as to
what goes on actually every day and a
lot of the documentation that does comes
out
is very difficult to sort of process and
doesn't necessarily have all the
information um that you need and
therefore you know if you're in academia
and you decide my bigger problem
actually with academia um or some
certain academic papers is that those
people don't necessarily live through
the things they're talking about you
know so they'll be talking about
currency swaps or credit derivatives and
they've never structured one you know i
don't believe you know you mentioned i
don't believe anyone in washington knows
what a swap is and you don't have to in
day-to-day life and that that's part of
what you know lyla discovers in the book
you don't need to know a lot but but if
you're making decisions and you're
enabling conditions that allow whatever
it is you don't understand to devastate
the economy then it's your
responsibility
to get out a spreadsheet and just like
like look at some numbers
um and and or find a person or do
anything that gives you some
understanding and at least have a basis
for what you're what you're deciding
upon which does not exist um in any of
the people i've spoken with in
washington yeah
i mean just quickly the only thing i'll
add to that is that um
it's not just that the
university level i think there's been a
lot written and there was an inside job
about how the banks are sponsoring
academics and they're behind a lot of
those research papers but
there's a tremendous movement afoot for
all the banks are getting heavily
involved in sponsoring
secondary education even elementary
school education if you go into
communities all across the country there
are a lot of these deals where a bank
will come to a a strug community that's
struggling financially and they'll say
here here's five million dollars for
your school system but in return we want
you to dissolve your teachers union or
you know we want this or that and there
it's kind of like the imf world bank
structural adjustment method where we
give you a whole bunch of money in
return we want your ideological
cooperation on this x y and z
right exactly and and they're they're
very very keen on doing that and i think
it shows how
how far reaching their their vision is
about society they don't have any
immediate benefit to doing that and
they're spending a lot of money on it
and that tells you that they're that
they have a very very broad vision for
how they want to impact the world and
keep the information out
right yeah
oh hi
sorry
uh you two are heroes so thank you very
much
and this is sort of to both of you uh do
you think we can stop them at the new
hampshire primary before they turn this
country into kind of a mad max nightmare
world
yeah i think
you know one of the things that occupy
wall street is really
bringing out is that there aren't any
obvious electoral solutions
to a lot of this and i think we kind of
we've kind of gone the route of trying
to fix this
at the at the ballot box because
you know the democratic party the
republican party they're
if you look historically the democrats
actually have
probably dirtier hands in terms of
deregulating this mess than the
republicans do and if you look at what
happened in dodd-frank uh the
negotiations last year that was a fiasco
as well you know there are a lot of
well-meaning people in washington you
know there were 33 votes to
to
start breaking up the banks and the
brown kaufman bill uh amendment but you
know that's it's not quite enough you
know i i don't i don't think there's any
i mean do you think there's a there's a
solution out there no it's a
presidential level well the presidential
level definitely the fact that you know
president obama has tim geithner as a
treasury secretary um right right there
is is is a
it's a rubber stamp to the idea of
subsidizing bailing out whatever term
you use for the way wall street acts and
the way wall street will continue to act
it's it's a big rubber stamp status quo
let's let's not touch anything because
and treasury sector is not about to turn
around say oops i made a mistake i
shouldn't have really backed bank of
america just because they bought all
this like crap from countrywide and
merrill lynch which by the way i said
they could do um you know between my
role the new york fed and ben bernanke
at the role of the fed head um they're
not going to turn around and ever admit
a mistake which which by the way is part
of the whole sociopathicness there's
there's there's the culpability at the
most powerful level you know where you
keep say banks big you keep them
structurally as they are you
you agree to large mergers that
shouldn't ever happen because they are
very unstable for the rest of the
economy
those people have no
incentive interest ability um to
consider anything they've done a mistake
i mean look look at what happened right
they you know you had this mess that was
because of concentration of capital and
what was
they concentrated in more they took the
the residue from all these banks and
they jammed them together and made them
more even more dangerous and and today
actually they're they're they're
re-restamping that you know bank of
america my my favorite negative bank is
today i change but is
uh taking a lot of the stuff that uh was
toxic from merrill lynch which uh
was something they purchased in the wake
of the financial crisis component of
2008 and they're basically putting it on
their deposit side so because banks are
not just big but complex they can be
like you know all this stuff over here
that we don't understand it's going to
lose money we're just going to mix it up
with deposits and that way you really
have to back us in case all of that
fails in case you didn't do that enough
the first time like we're doing it today
like like today this this you know the
fed is approving this so it's not only
that we've learned
nothing we continue to we're going
backwards um right now i think right and
then both parties have an equal hand in
parties quick comment when people with
the protest are accused of being
conspiracy theorists i wish the screen
read this is what they mean
thanks
well yeah i actually um that
does tell us pretty well i was going to
ask this about stuff that that you know
financial services companies are doing
now um
like there seems to be all this
volatility in the market like there's
this weird thing that
goldman tried to do with facebook there
seems to be some kind of tech bubble
emerging and and there are appear to be
investment banks shorting entire
countries in in europe if i unless i
misunderstand that it's very disturbing
to me that you would bet on the
destruction of italy that's that's i
wouldn't want to win that bet but i
don't know if you have any views about
that
i mean
that stuff is so is such a classic
example of what modern wall street is
all about it's it's like take the
example of greece right like you know
goldman goes into greece and they
and they uh
sell this country a gigantic raft of
interest rate swaps to basically what
are what are interest rate swaps do you
have a country that has a whole bunch of
debt they can't afford to pay it right
now and it's just really just a
mechanism to push the debt into the
future so that they the the current
spate of politicians doesn't have to
deal with it and the future generation
of politicians has a big bomb that's
going to go off in their face so it's
it's basically this symbiotic deal
between wall street and and the sitting
politicians it's like we'll lend you a
bunch of money now uh
so that future politicians can give us a
big bribe later well of course goldman
does this deal right which is going
enormously destabilizes greece and it
makes their long-term outlook extremely
negative and what do they do right away
they set up a mechanism to short grease
because they themselves have sold them
this stuff that is going to blow up and
that's an exact repeat of what happened
in the mortgage industry where they were
selling this stuff then they turned
right around and bet against it and then
when they broke their bookies doing that
and couldn't get their bets paid off
they made us pay it off uh through the
bailouts and that's that's exactly
what's going on with this euro bailout
right now they're going to get somebody
else to pay off those bets and actually
again in terms of history repeating
itself
that day i was telling you about black
thursday six big bankers got into a room
and they decided to pull up the market
they put in their own money it wasn't
federal money but but still put it one
of those was the head of what was chase
at the time now it's jp morgan chase it
was a morgan bank there's chase they've
gotten together
and um
he was in this room and he's like i'll
pledge this
it's you know our stock is going to be
worth it we're going to put in the
market all these you know little people
are going to buy stuff everything is
going to be great and meanwhile he set
up like five companies in like canada
run by you know the names of his
relatives and he's shorting the stock
right this guy's name's al wiggins he's
shorting the stock he's in the room they
call the new york times right after that
wall street junior banker save the day
blah blah the real headlines all over
the place on uh and he's off shorting
the stock and a year later when the
depression starts to really take hold
he's in europe
trying to figure out how to basically
get money out of
the european side of the crash
right so it's it's exactly the same it's
make money where you can when it falls
apart like move on i mean that that
that's kind of the most and again it's
not complicated and i think the one
thing that's one of the good things
that's coming out of the occupy wall
street movement is that it's showing you
you don't have to know every single
mechanic of every single detail of how
this happens you just have to know that
the impact that the ultimate result is
is bad and that there is a connection
and um
i think that that you know i i show it
in here through lila just understanding
that at a base level like what happens
if one person makes one bad decision on
one bad deal and what like how that not
just escalates in financial world and in
economy but how that escalates in in
people's real lives every day at home in
their family in in terms of mortality um
and so there's so many
connections
thank you matt for uh for letting
everybody know about how goldman uh
propped up a grease then only to short
it uh
really accurate portrayal um naomi uh
bill friedman said that the federal
reserve caused a great depression
and i would if you go along with that uh
line of reasoning that the federal
reserve constricted the or didn't allow
for the
monetary
supplies to increase
if you look at this current crisis
would you say that the federal reserve
bears responsibility as well
because of how they enabled the banks to
go ahead and have such an easy supply of
money
to lend out
that would allow for the mortgage
industry government bears its
responsibility for creating the
regulations but what
burden would you put on the federal
reserve for that and would you propose
the abolishing of the federal reserve
and if you would what would you put in
its place
um okay this could be a topic for
this is it's an excellent question so
i'm just going to give a very short
answer that we could honestly talk about
this a lot and it's a really good
question the the federal reserve and and
wall street are symbiotic right there
there is yeah printing money making
making uh the currency cheap giving out
cheap loans
is what has pumped a lot of the the
toxic asset market it's what's pumped a
lot of speculation it's what's allowed
banks to survive when they shouldn't be
solvent
um on the other hand it's banks that are
using that money to speculate and
leverage and do all these other things
so it's almost like the nature in which
the fed has enabled
wall street to do what wall street does
in its current form
is the danger so it is totally a
symbiotic danger back
in the great depression and i i take
issue with ben bernanke's whole i'm a
great depression scholar thing i mean i
know no i mean i know he's written a lot
of papers and he spent a lot of time and
that's fine but but again to go back to
a banker's a personal situation
one of the bankers sitting in that room
not the guy was shorting a stock another
one um was also also had a first class a
seat at the new york fed at the time so
the head of what was then citigroup city
national charles mitchell was also
sitting at the new york fed he actually
and this doesn't come up in ben
bernanke's papers
he was actually trying to get the fed to
keep rates low into the crash of 1929 to
keep money cheap and keep the
speculation going because his bank was
going to be screwed
if rates went up when he couldn't handle
that
and he had a lot of stock in his bank
and didn't want that to happen so he
basically
increased
the bubble that became the crash
personally
i mean other people but you know he had
he had a personal impact and right now
we have jamie dimon who's the head of
jpmorgan chase is sitting at the same
seat the same spot at the new york fed
able to have the conversations you know
with tim geithner over there you know to
talk about we need rates low now we need
cheap loans now you know if we don't the
economy is going to get worse or
whatever conversations are happening i
need 30 billion in guarantees to buy the
bears
and and and i'll just keep that forever
by the way let's never talk about the
fact that i only own bear stearns
because the fed i us are you know
financing it and the treasury
department's all okay with that so it's
not
the fact that the fed can both
regulate banks is allowed to tell them
how to behave or not behave to emerge or
not to merge which they never say not
they always say to
and print money when they screw up
is is is is a completely you know bad
economic policy it's morally hazardous
and all of those things so having the
fed be in control of regulating the
banking system when it also is allowed
to save it when it screws up is is just
not good for the rest of the economy
let me just add one really quick thing
about to that i mean one of the
criticisms that people like know that
nominee and i meet got
when we talked about all this stuff as
well you know you shouldn't criticize
people at goldman and jp morgan because
these guys are these guys are really
smart they earn their money because
they're the smartest guys in the world
and and they they deserve to get all
that money that they earn because
they're just so smart
if you're if you're borrowing money
billions of dollars from the fed at zero
percent and then you're going out and
lending it uh at five percent to the
rest of us or 25 in a credit card 29 or
29
and that's how you're making your money
what kind of does it take a genius to do
that
right i mean
god i mean a three-year-old could make a
billion dollars if you have that kind of
setup it's it's criminal with these guys
the fed
is basically a gigantic atm machine that
all these banks get to use they get free
money and then they lend it all out to
us at market rates and that's their
business that's how they all that the
the washington called this
recapitalizing the banks uh aft after
the crash and that's all it is free
money go get yourselves well and then
charge us the market rate and there's a
reason why there's not a lot of money
that comes back out there's a reason why
it's hard to negotiate a mortgage or
renegotiated to renegotiate a student
loan or to get a small business loan
because they
wouldn't want to do that if they can
basically be getting money for free and
and using it in any capacity there's no
there's no attachment there's no there's
no obligation there's no economic
obligation to actually spread it around
and there wasn't back then except then
the the issue was there were more
farmers than other kinds of businessmen
and there was a lot of conversation
which doesn't happen in ben bernanke's
papers about how they were trying to
suppress loans to the farmers which
ultimately also helped create the great
depression and and now it's you know
it's not farmers it's kind of everybody
um and farmers also but but it's the
same mechanism it's it's the we keep it
low
we restrain when we have problems we get
bailed out when we have problems um and
whatever happens on the outside it's an
accident of nature
it's the economy it's the cycle it's
it's
the
way things are
yeah
i i
i have a question um i know what it's
like for a typical day to work in a
bookstore what's it like to work for
deimos for a think tank what's it what
how is it structured
okay
now naomi works for demos too she's a
senior fellow my my typical day is um
i have a series of long-term projects
i'm working that are related on culture
and politics and i work on those but i
also follow what's going on on a daily
basis whether it be occupy wall street
whether it be election issues and i'll
write and comment and research on those
so there's no typical day per se but
that's what i typically do
it's also very much i mean what you do
is it's also very much about what's
happening right now and how these
policies whether they're on democracy
whether economic policies are impacting
people
right now and rather than just saying
they are actually coming up with you
know good solid information that
people can use when they talk about the
issues
this has been an absolutely incredible
evening thank you all very very much my
question gets back to it something matt
said that we'd never see these
individuals prosecuted and i hear that
but uh eric schneiderman and beau biden
and there is a group of people who are
trying to defend the bondholders and to
make sure that doesn't happen given
everything that's going on with occupy
wall street where americans are becoming
interested in informed thanks to you and
i hope uh we see an awful lot more of
you all
on tv and everywhere what can we be
doing and how can we institute some sort
of change to see these people
prosecuted and also to have a better
future all the way around
that's that's a good question i mean the
obvious answer is
write letters protest all all these
things i you know i think politicians
are
rapidly becoming aware that that if they
sweep this whole foreclosure thing under
the rug
that they're playing with fire i mean
there's four million people already out
in the streets because they lost their
homes
and that that's just lighting a fuse if
they if they decide not to get take
anybody to jail for all that stuff and
and and and also give them immunity from
civil liability um i think they're
making a huge mistake and politicians
you know we saw the attorney general in
california has already doubled back i
think they're very very sensitive to
public pressure right now obviously we
have a good one here in new york who's
already not going to jump on board with
that but if you're from another state
i think they're listening so you know
letters show public support i think all
that stuff
actually is i mean even though they're
not at that level the senate or the you
know in washington per se i think the
collective pressure that they can exude
if they hear what's going on and they're
doing their jobs um you know prosecuting
at the at the foreclosure fraud level
and also taking that all the way up to
um the ceo level because
that that fraud is something that's that
remains in every single asset that is
created all the way up the line from
the one home and the one mortgage that
might have been fraudulently created to
you know the mega cdo
wrapped synthetic you know whatever
thing that's on the other side of that
that the fraud continues it doesn't stop
because it's passed to the next level
but i think i think that
uh i i used to say the same thing you
write your congresswoman right and there
is something to be said for that i think
the occupy wall street room is a visible
movement so so help to that actually as
a representative movement of everybody
um is is useful and also the the
attorney general route i've been finding
more and more um is a good accessible
route as well just really quick on that
uh one of the narratives that that is
that people are trying to the banks are
trying to push about the foreclosure
thing is that this is all about
paperwork this is you know we
maybe we we didn't transfer the deeds
properly that's all this thing is about
if that's not what it's all about this
is a massive systematic cover-up where
they with the what they were talking
about is a
gigantic industry-wide effort at selling
crap as chanel number five uh to to
investors all around and and
if i think a couple of ag's like
schneiderman are they they're on the
scent they recognize that there is a lot
of political hate to be made i mean if
you go down that route with
investigating securitization that whole
aspect of all this they could be making
cases till the next century basically
and i think a lot of smart attorneys
general are real are realizing that that
that's where the that's where the money
is and that
and a little push and they'll go there
you know a um there have been some
prosecutions but they're odd though if a
a ceo or a
member of a board of directors has a
fiduciary responsibility to his
shareholders he'll always tell you that
so if i were a shareholder
and my
ceo when he was about to sell these uh
this junk
said oh but it'll hurt that little old
lady in the pension fund in minneapolis
i could sue him
i could sue him but he has to put my
fiduciary responsibility first and if
the guy is decent as i'm talk to the
kind of people who are decent what
they'll say is make it against the law
then i won't have to do it in other
words stop me before i kill again
so there have been some suits but you
know
take think back to enron
the suits were not enron for raising the
price of electricity in california to
the point that it broke the state and
ruined the educational system
but only
when you kept secrets from other
shareholders when you tried to pass it
off on the shareholders so it was only
on behalf of shareholders that suits
have been brought i mean that's really a
shameful system these guys will tell you
i'm not even allowed to think about the
common good yeah but but
i would quit
them we just have to control them i
would i would quibble with that only in
the sense that what these guys were
doing was was criminal it was there was
fraud it was against the law and by and
by doing it it was against the law i
mean i if you're if you're taking if
you're taking a
gigantic batch of subprime mortgages
from countrywide which you know is a
criminal organization that is that is
giving out
fraudulent loans
you know this you have you have
information that you are not moving
along so you also know that right so you
you know that and then and then you're
knowingly unloading them on people and
not disclosing those facts you're
committing a crime and that's incurring
a much bigger liability than potential
liability than missing out on the
profits by not selling that that thing
so i would argue that they they created
a much bigger problem for their
shareholders by doing this than they
than they would have by not doing it and
under securities fraud laws a lot of
this stuff could be prosecuted the whole
reason the sec was created was to
investigate a lot well was to basically
keep the kinds of trusts and the kinds
of weird things where we were selling
chanel and calling it chanel and selling
whatever else was inside it that was
basically the sec's job was to
protect the public from public fraud
from the securities that were created by
these institutions that impact the
public being fraudulent you know so it's
it's it's a really yeah
i don't get to prosecute this stuff but
i mean it's it's
it's very
it's much less complicated than they
make it out to be
yes um well someone kind of asked a
related question about solutions and
your answer kind of scares me a little
bit because
a lot of what your books are about is
how these solutions aren't working right
so
um
these solutions don't get adopted right
like just presidential uh we think they
could or i yeah i think
there's some basic solutions the
question do you protect the economy
the general population do you protect
the banking
institutions
my question more is though um
doesn't there need to be a shift in the
way we view these things though because
um i think a lot of the problem is like
matt mentions in his book that
there isn't
this isn't seen as criminality by
everybody and so what can we do to kind
of change the mind state of our country
where we actually see this as outright
criminality because i feel like i just
personally i feel like that's a lot of
the
problem uh and that's probably on the
media more than anything right i mean i
i think
yeah i don't think a lot of the media
said that security they've committed
securities fraud securities fraud is
illegal they've committed illegal acts
they should be prosecuted and penalized
yeah we don't we don't see a lot of that
but you know
as as regards solutions i think
like there's there's going to be a huge
debate down the road about things that
need to be done and then and you know
the right is going to have its
traditional solution of
deregulation and and the other the other
side is going to say let's have more
regulation but i think even before we
get there there's a lot of really
obvious steps when we have to end this
sort of unhealthy plutocratic or you
know symbiotic relationship between
government and wall street that but
neither side agrees on i think i don't
think anybody on the right or the left
agrees that our tax dollars should be
going to pay lloyd blankfein's bonus
right i mean that i don't think nobody
agrees to that nobody nobody believes
that uh you know stevie cohen or george
soros or john paulson should be paying
half the tax rate of a fireman or a
teacher uh i think that's something that
everybody can agree upon so there are a
lot of things break up the banks a lot
of things that are obvious solutions and
then there's you know the more
complicated policy discussion down the
road yeah one of the reasons i wrote a
novel instead of the non-fiction this
time around was because there's that you
know you sometimes have to take a break
from like yelling about the solutions
for for like almost
however many years i've been doing this
it was sort of like let me let me go
into at least another time another
period look at this a different way you
know touch a human side of it because
the solutions aren't
that difficult either it's it's the will
to get there right
there's so much money
that's the will problem
hello hi uh my name is george uh i've
been down to occupy wall street a number
of times and uh my contribution is in a
pictorial i'd like to hand it to you uh
it made uh
meet the press in um
in their first 15 seconds of last two
sundays ago
i hung that that's a skeleton holding a
a placard saying throw me some crumbs
and i think it's how the 99 certainly
feel it's been very well photographed uh
my question though i'm trying to get the
group down there to focus on what i
think are the two most important
overarching initiatives which dylan
radigan seems to have one covered and
that's uh campaign finance reform but i
think that's going to be a really
i think that's going to be a really
difficult thing to do a constitutional
amendment it's going to be carefully
written
with you know
tricky parameters and the worst part is
that we need both of our illustrious
politicians
to vote on it and now since the debt
ceiling crisis when they played
political chicken with each other we
don't seem to have any confidence in
either one of them so my question to you
if it's a question sort of is do you
think that campaign finance reform is
one of the best ways to go about fixing
what's wrong with our government or do
we also need uh to actually change our
voting system from single vote into
something like score voting to level the
playing field so that third and fourth
party candidates will have an equal
chance to win this and we'll be able to
actually vote
instead of have being forced to feel
that we have to vote for the
democrat or the republican we'll be able
to actually vote for anybody that we
want to and everybody that we want to
and pick the guys who are the more
generally preferred moderate centrists
when they're they're not even on the
ballot now
so that's sort of a question
thank you yeah i'm i think just just a
real simple answer that yeah if if we
get
money out of politics
that leaves
real issues and real solutions and real
activities in politics and um and so you
know the the campaign finance reform the
fact that we went in the again this is
another thing in the last few years we
go in the opposite direction of what
makes sense to be more palatable for the
general population and and the supreme
court decision regarding campaign
finance reform is just another example
of a recent happening of that so if the
people that run
are
you know require the money that comes in
from whether it's corporate sponsorship
or wall street and president obama this
year a second largest
group contributor is is the financial
industry um so you know if they're
keeping your you or your job
you're gonna
sort of do what you need to do to stay
in power and and so that definitely
should be disconnected
just just really quickly on that um
you know from my own personal experience
from covering the dodd-frank bill and
when i was down in the senate um at that
time really interesting
statistic the financial services
industry had 2 000 lobbyists in the
halls of congress during that bill the
other side
which was like americans for financial
reform had 60 volunteer lobbyists
and i was
i remember very distinctly being in one
senator's office actually was one of our
senators uh and not having room to stand
in the in the waiting room because there
were so many industry lobbyists in the
in the waiting room uh so
the problem of money in this whole i
mean look there was a lot of reforms
that got
passed in the dodd-frank bill despite
this avalanche of money that got thrown
at all these these members of congress
which just shows you how
you know it was what they were asking
for was so wrong
and and the other side was so was so
appealing to the to whatever was left of
the conscience of these congressional
members uh that they actually did do a
few things despite the fact that all the
money was on one side and none of it was
on the other side so i think if you can
get some at least even half the money
out you'll you'll start to see a lot of
movement and i think you know that's
i just want to add something very quick
question here just let me get something
please go forward
last question can i just add something
okay excuse me
okay
hi uh just by the way matt to your point
about the greek uh swap deal the goldman
partner who arranged that is now the
head of the public debt management
agency for greece the socialist
government by the way
hey um
nami do you really think that dodd-frank
deconcentrates financial power or
doesn't it re-concentrate it by making
it uh further concentrated by raising
the transaction costs to a point where
and complexity to a point where only the
largest institutions can navigate
through it
well i think even more than that the
dodd-frank bill does does nothing to
change the current complexity or size it
does not split up banks it does not
reduce their ability to create complex
assets and call them gold when they are
not um it does it i i don't find the
dodd-frank bill does very much of of
anything that will be meaningful at all
um so
i think one uh
one member of congress that i talked to
had a great way of describing what
happened with dodd-frank pills anyone
here read old man in the sea
uh you know so the guy from sherman goes
out he catches this huge fish and he's
all stoked about it and then he starts
going back to shore and by the time he
gets back to shore there's like a
skeleton left behind the boat that's
exactly what happened at dodd-frank
there are all these great ideas
that came out in the beginning and by
the time all the lobbyists got done with
that bill there was literally nothing
left that all got eaten away in those
last minute discussions behind the
scenes and that was a sort of a classic
example of how the public doesn't really
see how the real work gets done all
those public things we saw in c-span and
uh the arguments on the floor of the
house that really it just disappeared in
the middle of the night in those
committee discussions which was really
really sad though we did have a point in
time where they they did pass so i mean
they didn't now which is again very sad
for now but when they did pass in 1933
they did create a somewhat more stable
uh banking system
economic environment and so
again those solutions exist the the
problem is getting
them to happen
i think we're going to move on
before that we have one another thing to
talk about
the um thank you to the tenant museum
we're kind of strand bookstores kind of
going oprah winfrey but one person under
their seat has a
two-person membership for the tenement
museum for
for one year and um
research for the tech
does it get the win
so thank you so much rich know me and
matt for such a spirited and you guys
for great questions spirited discussion
[Applause]